a clear mind leads to better judgment
leads to better outcome so a happy
calm peaceful person will make better
decisions and have better outcomes so if
you want to operate at peak performance
you have to learn how to tame your mind
just like you have to learn how to tame
your body
[Music]
let's go back to desire right this is
old old buddhist wisdom i'm not saying
anything original but
desire to me is a contract that you make
with yourself to be unhappy until you
get what you want
okay and i keep that in front of mine so
when i'm unhappy about something i look
for what is the underlying desire that i
have that's not being fulfilled it's
okay to have desires you're a biological
creature you're put on this earth you
have to do something you have to have
desires you have a mission but don't
have too many don't pick them up
unconsciously don't pick them up
randomly don't have thousands of them my
coffee is too cold doesn't taste quite
right i'm not sitting perfectly oh i
wish it would warmer uh you know my dog
you know pooped in the lawn i don't like
that whatever it is pick your one
overwhelming desire it's okay to suffer
over that one but on all the others you
want to let them go so you can be calm
and peaceful and relaxed and then you'll
perform a better job
most people when you're unhappy like a
depressed person
it's not that they have very clear calm
mind they're too busy in their mind
their sense of self is too strong
they're sitting indoors all the time
their minds working working working
they're thinking too much well if you
want to be a high performance athlete
how good of an athlete are you going to
be if you're always having epileptic
seizures if you're always like twitching
and running around and like jumping and
your your limbs are flailing out of
control the same way if you want to be
effective in business you need a clear
calm cool collected mind warren buffett
plays bridge all day long and goes for
walks in the sun he doesn't sit around
like constantly loading his brain with
non-stop information and and getting
worked up about every little thing
we live in an age of infinite leverage
what i mean by that is that your actions
can be multiplied a thousand-fold either
by broadcasting at a podcast or by
investing capital or by having people
work for you or by writing code
so because of that the impacts of good
decision making are much higher than
they used to be
because now you can influence thousands
or millions of people through your
decisions or your code
so
a clear mind leads to better judgment
leads to better outcome so a happy
calm peaceful person will make better
decisions and have better outcomes so if
you want to operate at peak performance
you have to learn how to tame your mind
just like you have to learn how to tame
your body so assuming that your goal is
your your motivation is intrinsic you're
doing the thing because you love it or
because you really want it and you can
separate that motivation from anxiety
then i think you can take on certain
superpowers and we kind of all
intrinsically know this like if you look
at you know samurai warriors right like
miyamoto musashi is in a duel with
somebody else you know that the person
who is calmer is going to win in all
those movies it's the one who can like
who's like incredibly still then swipes
with a sword incredibly quickly and then
still again that's the winner the one
who has a zen state of mind similarly in
the terminator movies part of the reason
you fear the terminator is because he's
a robot he's unstoppable he's implacable
you can't argue with him you can't
communicate with him you can't make him
slow down and he has no remorse he just
keeps coming or in that old clintuswood
movie unforgiven you know the guy who
wins the gunfight is the one who doesn't
flinch he's just keeping his cool while
he's loading his gun and shooting he's
not like all over the place running
around so i just think we waste so much
energy through anxiety that if you can
be calm and still go about your business
it's a superpower and i i realized this
myself recently where i was in a
conflict situation in business it was a
high conflict situation it was
unfortunate we i think we've solved it
but as i went through this high conflict
situation i'd been through one like it
years before where i was much more
anxious and i remember that time period
i remember how much i was sweating it
and how nervous i was and how i went
through bouts of fear and anger and and
how kind of worked up i was the entire
time intense and didn't get much sleep
but this time i was incredibly calm and
i was almost enjoying it because it was
like practicing my craft now of course
it's easier to do now because i have
more money but at the same time
it just didn't bother me it was just
very mechanical and because of that i
could be very effective about it and i
could be effective about it while doing
lots and lots of other things my mind
wasn't constantly spinning in a
whirlpool taking on ten different
problems and just fear based on
aeroplaning all the time
most of these things were never going to
happen so i do believe that being calm
and still going about your business is
the superpower now yes if anxiety is
your only motivator then you have a
problem but i would argue the pure
motivations don't come out of anxiety so
let's talk about
attribution here to what would you
attribute the and i know this that it's
difficult to isolate variables etc but
if let's just say like you have a family
so let's just say one of your kids comes
to you it's like dad i'm suffering from
a lot of anxiety
what should i do or you observe it and
you want to help your kid out what types
of recommendations would you make or
might you make another question if you
prefer it is what has helped you to go
from
the whirlpool experience of anxiety in
high conflict experience round one
versus calm neval and high conflict
experience round two
yeah it's really hard to separate all
the pieces out i mean it comes from a
combination of
philosophy yoga meditation
getting older having kids you know like
you i've i've had some psychedelic
experiences but those are very far back
in the past
just a distant memory at this point but
i would say the number one thing that
has been very very important for me is
meditation and it's a stupid thing to
say because so trite everybody just says
it now but when i say meditation i don't
mean sitting there and watching your
breath or chanting a mantra i mean
self-examination
and meditation is a great way to do that
self-therapy it's sitting there with
your thoughts
so anxiety the anxiety anxiety this this
pervasive non-specific anxiety we were
just constantly on edge about everything
that comes from an unexamined life you
know i think what's the socrates said
like an unexamined life is not worth
living i forget who said that quote
something like that yeah but it's it's
not all soccer one of those one of those
smart philosopher types but it's correct
it's your unexamined life that is
causing the problems and you can examine
it in multiple ways you can examine it
through you can have some crazy mushroom
trip where it all comes out one night
you could do a lot of meditation sitting
there with yourself and letting your
mind run crazy and then seeing what's
actually in your mind that your mind
wants to tell you and have you listened
to and have you resolved that is
unresolved it could be through therapy
it could be through reading lots of
philosophy and reflection and long walks
so there's many many ways to tackle it
but it's that spending that time with
yourself to examine why are you having
these thoughts think about it this way
we spend so much time in our
relationships our relationship with our
wives our relationship with our
colleagues our relations to our business
partners our relations with our friends
the most important relationship you have
is with yourself it's with this voice in
your head that is constantly rattling
every waking hour it's this crazy
roommate living inside your mind who's
always chattering always chattering
never shuts up and you can't control
these thoughts they just come up out of
you don't even know where
that quality of those quality of your
thoughts that convers those
conversations you're having in your head
all the time that is your world that is
the world you live in those that's the
world view you have that's the lenses
you see through and that's going to
determine the quality of your life more
than anything else and if you want to
see what the quality of your life
actually is put down the drink put down
the computer put down the smartphone put
down the book put down the headphones
just sit by yourself doing nothing and
then you will know what the quality of
your life actually is because that's
what you're always running away from
that's why people when they try to
meditate to sit down like i hate it i
can't sit still why because your mind is
eating you live your life is unexamined
your mind is running in loops over
things that it has not resolved and
because they're not resolved when you
run around your normal life it's not
those problems have gone away it's that
they're just there they're there and but
they're provoking anxiety and what you
think of as the anxiety that's that's
kind of consuming you and you can't
identify the source that's just the tip
of an iceberg poking out from underneath
the water and underneath this giant pile
of garbage of decisions that were made
without too much thought of situations
that you're in that you haven't resolved
that you need to resolve of problems
that you have or desires that you have
that have gone unmet or unmanifested or
contradictions that you're living in or
ways that you which you feel trapped so
proper meditation proper examination
should
ruin the life that you're currently
living it should cause you to leave
relationships it should cause you to
re-establish boundaries with family
members and with colleagues it should
cause you to quit your job it should
cause you to change your eating patterns
it should cause you to spend more time
with yourself it should cause you to
change what books you read it should
cause you to change who your friends are
if it doesn't do that it's not real
examination if it doesn't come attached
with destruction of your current life
then you can't create the new life in
which you will not have the anxiety if
you look at the greatest competitors in
the worlds greatest physical athletes
marcela garcia who's a who i trained
with for many years who i own a jiu
jitsu school within the city um
if you he's probably the greatest
grappler to ever live and if you watch
marcelo in a world championship
he would be sleeping literally minutes
before
um
a
semi-final final sleeping
and but you've never seen anyone turn on
more intensely and if you look at great
fighters people think fighters are like
jacked and intense but they're not like
they're actually very relaxed the
greatest fighters are super relaxed when
they're not fighting but when they're in
the battle you wouldn't believe the
intensity and even to deconstruct that
further if you watch a great for example
boxer
the relaxation before a strike is
delivered is incredible
so does the undulation like most people
in
high stress decision making industries
are always operating at this kind of
simmering six
or four
as opposed to the undulation between
just deep relaxation and being out of
ten and being at a ten is like millions
of times better than being at a six it's
not
it's just in that different universe
same same as being all in on a
discipline is millions of times more
intense than being
you know 98 or 99 let alone you know i
could take it or leave it you know and
just having observed you observed
marcelo yeah uh certainly heard stories
about say floyd mayweather before
gigantic fights and uh i heard a friend
of mine who knows him said he walked
into his dressing room after floyd was
like yeah sure come on in he's like i
don't want to interrupt you you must be
prepping and he's like no i'm either
ready or i'm not and he was just sitting
down watching some tv
that
it's
it's
in a way
your ability to avoid the simmering six
directly affects your ability to then
ratchet up to turn on to the 99 or 100
right if you're always at a simmering
six
you're just at 50 battery
right all the time 100 percent and 50
percent intensity and you cannot you
have no idea what your 10 is
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you